there's two applications to consider
along with a report on plant appeals i
am happy with this and intend to take
the business and be able to set out on
the agenda
someone who's apologist for absence
yes chad uh we've received apologies
from councillor r hall substituted by
councillor s club
councillor l hartson is substituted by
councillor t lacey
cancer m foster and substituted by
councillor elle dave
we've also received apologies from
councillor eight powell
and councillor dean hancock thank you
thank you
i don't think this is in your mouth
item two declarations of interest
members are requested to declare the
existence and nature of any disposable
procurement interest and or other
interests not already on their register
of interest
when any item on the agenda i would saw
from
minutes of the last meeting we now have
the minutes of our meeting held on
tuesday the 26th of july 2022.
are we happy that they are in correct
record
and if so is there any movement
thank
any abstentions
[Music]
we have two applications but before we
start i would like the client to explain
to the benefits of members speakers and
those watching on youtube and we deal
with them
right thank you chair
this is the procedure for considering
the business this afternoon
the chair will introduce the application
and ask the planning officers to refer
members to any late comments or updates
received since the agenda was published
these have now been published on the
council's website and hard copies have
been circulated to you
after this the chair will ask any
speakers to address the meeting
there's only one speaker registered
today who will be speaking on the first
application
they will have three minutes to put
forward their views
there will be a reminder given by the
client and thirty second unit
at the end of the three minutes members
of the committee will have an
opportunity to ask the speaker questions
if necessary
in order to clarify any points they have
made
after the speaker has addressed the
committee and answered any questions
they will be allowed to remain in the
meeting but they will not be allowed to
participate further from that point
the chair will then open the meeting for
questions to officers it will then be a
debate by the committee and finally a
determination on the application by a
vote
the votes will be taken by rulebook
primary members
this meeting is being recorded which
will then be placed on the council's
website
note that others may choose to copy this
recording
thank you chad
thank you that moves us on to the first
application
which is ned4
i'm going to ask the planning officers
to tell us about any late comments and
to give a brief presentation showing
many photos and plans at the site
i will allow the offices to complete the
presentations consequently members could
you please reserve any points
until the end thank you
the application in effect
seeks to retain the existing benefits
for the purposes of cafe use over to the
excuse me would you be able to talk just
a little bit more into the light yeah
in addition the application also seemed
to attain associated development
including attached extension to the cafe
building which is used for the purposes
of the baby shop and booking office
associated with the phishing values
in summary due to the circumstances set
out in the community report including
the recent assessments for local
development supplication
in addition officers do not consider
that to be the technical reasons why the
application should not be supported next
time
so the first slide shows the site
location plan which shows the specific
side application edged in red with
additional bandwidth shaped
the next slide shows the site layout
plan which shows designing great detail
including the build development of the
application
namely the cafe building and touch page
shop
track that joins the highway at keeper's
lane and starting castle
the track crosses far overlooked by a
great series to bridge the league bridge
which is also marked on the plan
this plan also shows the nearest
residential property application site
which positioned at the junction of this
lane encapsulating and attached to the
gray
device
excited
so moving on to the plans um
this is
a slide shows that the postal sport
plans
you can tell
the build for which the application
seems to be saying
the top line shows
[Music]
is shielded
moving on some photos to the application
site
this photo shows the extent of the build
development which the application seems
to obtain so
forth round is the cafe with the veranda
which is a
tradition as well at the front and
beyond that you can just about see the
bait shop which is which is attached
next step is
so this this slide shows the budget
rather shows the
building and context of the existing
fishing lights
so this shows the view towards the site
access
and traffic on the site it also shows
more areas that are used currently for
parking vehicles
for those used
finally this shows the access track and
the bridge
this is the track on which the
application site is accessed there's
also
these conditions
thank you i believe we have one speed
for this application
and that's the agent dark hand who will
be joining us by soon as the craft
explained he will have three minutes to
get over his points he will be informed
with 30 seconds remaining
as members you can ask him to clarify
any matters that have been raised but
remember your question should only
engage the points which is
brilliant thank you well thank you chair
thank you members um my name is doug han
from wsp and i'm speaking uh on behalf
of the application today
the fisherman's friends cafe is an
important facility at the fisheries
complex and has been serving the
fishermen and local community using a
site for many many years
the applicants acquired the site shortly
before the uh pandemic and have spent a
lot of time energy and money in
upgrading and tidying up the site and
improving the facilities
and the cafe is a critical element of
that um with the fisheries being a long
established use that's been uh enjoyed
by local people for decades
the cafe as you've seen sits well within
the fisheries complex it's it's well
screened by significant tree stands and
vegetation and of itself is a relatively
modest cabin structure which has been
serving hot cold food next
for many years to fishermen people
walking through the site riding bikes
etc and also members of the local
community perhaps walking their dogs um
the the veranda was added in part due to
covered uh restrictions that have been
brought into place
um
the we're pleased that officers uh
consider the development is an
appropriate use in the green belt
as we do and that the relatively modest
scale of what is there uh accords with
greenbelt policy about encouraging
outdoor use and recreation and certainly
the the facility does it serves people
who are enjoying the outdoors at a
fishery complex and wider area
the
cafe has been improved as you've seen
from the photo just displayed by uh by
the officer then to to create an
attractive
structure within the site
which blends in with the the the wooded
surroundings and we believe is it is a
you know a pleasant structure that not
only serves a good purpose but is in
keeping with the area
the
office's report has shown that there are
all technical matters that have been
resolved and there aren't any concerns
around noise over or nuisance um with
the the cafe being cited uh around 100
metres away from the nearest property
with a substantial area woodland between
um
from a highways perspective it's
encouraging to see that the derbyshire
county council highway officer confirms
that the proposals are acceptable in
their views and won't cause a
significant adverse effect upon the
highway which is it's not surprising
given that it's been operational in its
current form for quite a while um the
access to the site is down it's down
narrow lanes but but they are are narrow
and speeds are low and fishermen tend to
visit the site and spend a long time
they're fishing
rather than coming and going um the
revised hours set out in the officers
report are helpful as they fit with
especially summer opening hours
and
therefore overall we are pleased with
the offices report and we support the
recommendation and respectfully hope
that you are able to support it too
thank you
have any questions for the speaker
that's our answer
thank you chad
yeah it's uh
oh very interesting what you have to say
why didn't uh your applicants apply for
plenty permission in the first place and
then we
can't just put buildings up without
planning permission
can you explain please
yes yes i can um
the
committee report sets out
a sort of complex history um our client
the current owners acquired the site
around 2019 20 um with the building
largely as as you've seen on the photos
before you they added the veranda and
the the tackle shop um the building
origi originally as the officer report
states um
hadn't been built in accordance with the
2012 permission so that was almost 10
years ago um the applicant wasn't aware
that putting a veranda on would have
constituted any form of development and
the tax shop or the bait shop you'll see
is a a very small structure
they they undertook those works before
seeking our advice um
as planning concerns we would advise
them of the need for those consents um
but
we've reached reached a position where
we needed to try and uh work through to
get a
sort of reconciliation of what is there
now on the site um and that's that's the
purpose of making the application now is
effectively to tidy up um the situation
in terms of what is there on site
uh surely uh
when the applicant bought this
uh property he would have done the
search and the search should have shown
up
[Music]
in response to that and i i can't
comment as i wasn't involved at that
time and and
um i'll say i haven't seen anything from
any legal searches um however i think as
the officer report suggests
the
the drawings for the consent from 2012
uh were pretty much hand-drawn drawings
were not terribly accurate
and
it it took quite a lot of work between
uh the officers and ourselves to to get
to position that the building built
wasn't in accordance with the original
plans the the original plans are not
very accurate in terms of what they
portray um and so there was permission
for a cafe building it's just that what
had been built was not not fully in
accordance with those plans it was a
building roughly in the right location
um and of a similar configuration but
but but a little bit larger than the
consented plans from 2012 um but the the
amount of information is pretty limited
so that's why
it took a while for it to come to light
as part of the the planning process that
it
it it didn't have a permission but there
has always been a permission on the site
for a cafe building
and there has been uh it's been granted
two times and there's so that has always
been a permission it's just um it has
transpired that what is there does not
fully match what was on the original
consent from 2012
yeah i'd just like to clarify you just
said that dcc have got no concerns well
according to this from what i can read
at 7.37
they've actually said that they want
part of the um the lane widened by
and so that there's no sort of um cars
waiting and that and i do worry about
the access to this area so
um
so why did you say the dcc had no
concerns where the planning officers and
ecc have said that they you know this
area needs to be widened
if i didn't say it i meant to say they
had no objections and yes there's a
condition requiring a a short length
length widening of a short length of the
access way um but their their overall
conclusions are that there isn't a
significant adverse effect uh upon the
highway um and the the the access
effectively serves the fishery and has
done for for many many decades um so
yeah with the condition proposed which
which which is reasonable um the dcc
haven't raised any highway objections
um
i i mean i've been looking at it just
briefly and i i find that quite quite
amazing that dcc haven't because
if this is going to be opened up to the
public even more i think the traffic
will be a lot more so the access is
going to be causing a lot of problems
it's not just for walkers and
their cyclists and also you know the
bridge i worry about that with it being
a listed bridge it's very old
i mean is there anything that's going to
be done to sort of strengthen that for
the amount of vehicles maybe heavy goods
vehicles that will be going over with
food lovers and things like that i mean
i might be out of context here but from
reading it that's what what i'm worried
about
in in in terms of access um the the the
what the applicant should play
applications seeking is pretty much
what's been happening over the last ten
years in so far as the cafe has been
operating um to serve the fishermen and
and others visiting the site and i think
you'll probably appreciate from the
scale of the of the cafe it's it's
pretty small um
it is
it is a facility that serves like
largely the fishermen on the site or
people walking through um it of itself
won't generate a lot of traffic uh the
fishery it generates the majority of the
traffic that visits the site because
people are bringing equipment um but the
cafe itself is not such a scale it's
going to attract people driving to it
for miles um the the existing access um
it is established and has been in use
for as i say many many years um in terms
of visits to the site the majority of
visits are cars um
and
given the scale of the cafe building um
it it shouldn't and doesn't need
significant amounts of servicing i know
there was a photo in the in the late
pack showing
a larger vehicle visiting the site but
i'd imagine that that's probably a very
rare occurrence because i'd imagine that
most vehicles visiting the site will be
smaller vehicles because of the scale of
the facility it doesn't require
significant amounts of servicing and you
know many local people who wrote in and
supported proposals will clearly walk
down there it's a pleasant walking route
and bridal way so um
in that respect um it it shouldn't there
shouldn't be a significant change to the
current situation really in terms of in
terms of in terms of use because that's
how it's been operating for around 10
years um regards to the bridge um no
works are being proposed to the bridge
um you're right it is a an old listed
bridge but no works are being proposed
and and none are being suggested as
required in order to uh to make the use
acceptable it's more about um
regularizing the the the cafe building
but the use of a cafe and the fisheries
has has been going on for decades on the
site
i think some of my thunders have been
stolen
yes i have an issue with the road in
road out i'm sure somebody somewhere
could look at making that one way in off
the bend and then exiting onto overlease
and not being able to turn left so you
can turn right down into barlow and spin
around however probably would make it
safer i have an issue with the bridge as
well if that if that should
looking at it now with the refuge
lorries and the
anything that's going to pump in and
bump out as the pictures show in the
back
they're they're quite significant
worries now so if that bridge fails
who who actually bears the burden to the
cost to pull another eye
that that isn't anything that i i'm i
i've got
information on that imagine if it's
it's not in the applicant's ownership i
don't believe
um and if it's a if it's a bridal way
bridge but it it's an established
established access point to the
fisheries which has had vehicles passing
over it for many
yeah i mean i i i i'm not sure when
those photos were taken um but i'm not
aware that huge tanker lorries would
visit the site i'm not sure what reason
they would be for visiting the site um
you know the small cafe building doesn't
generate the need for huge tankers um so
i'm not sure the context of that picture
or when it when it was taken um i know
from the photos which were in the late
pack which showed cars queuing up um the
the operators suggest that he wasn't
sure when that was taken but the only
time they've ever had cues was when the
pandemic was lifted and the first day
people were desperate the first day they
opened people were desperate to get back
fishing um but but generally speaking
you've seen from the photos it's a
pretty modest cabin um it doesn't need
significant large vehicles to service it
um
so
um
yeah i don't believe that there's a
particular issue with large vehicles
visiting the site on a regular basis
mean i do um down there and uh i
certainly go down for breakfast on the
sunday you know and so on and so forth
not sure whether she would be playing
that's interesting
the flip side to it is i'm only worried
about the bridge bridge is quite a
significant bridge
and it worries me if that does fail
who's going to pay for it that that
bothers me
you obviously read the pack
3.2 the original replacement building
the usage was conditioned on um the
snack cabin being used purely and
somewhere for fishing members although
myself who's not a fishing member must
be sneaking in uh also uses it so
there is a lot more traffic and i think
something does need doing with the
traffic down one way and then out the
other uh
but the rest of it you know i'm quite
happy with the building
no issue with that i just think there
are a few fundamental things to get
right with it thank you
thank you are there any other questions
thank you very much
are there any questions for planning
[Music]
the
gentleman just about the bridging
repairs and the dcc bit where we could
use one lane in one way now i'm sure
or do something about it to make it a
little bit safer for the people walking
up and down
i've never seen it as bad as it is in
this pack that's for sure and i do watch
it quite regularly
so i i don't have those concerns but i
would like to see something from
comments on that agent please just on
that
chair
obviously to my left right
thoughts on this as well but the issue
of
vehicle management is not something that
we've gone into any detail with with the
applicant
and if
how that may work and
my
own view chair i set out in the
so i don't know how much traffic that
would be without the cafe used at all
because it's just seemed to me to be
well used and not patronized
but that would be something we would
need to discuss with the applicant if
the event would possibly have a one-way
and one-way axis which would involve
this
i'm
just in terms of the
listed bridge
again as we set out in the report the
maintenance of the bridge was thought to
be over
so if there were shoes in terms of its
maintenance repair that would fall
together but would it be a holistic
bridge there is a requirement to
[Music]
we've consulted the county council
highway authority but they've not
indicated that they are
using the bridge
and the the condition that's recommended
by officers would require the
widely to the track closest to some of
the house lane to avoid cars cueing back
onto the highway that's the reason why
you're in that condition
and there's been no suggestions for the
effort at all
as you've mentioned that condition is
maintainable or inappropriate but we did
not
source any more information
i'm happy with the with the things in
front of us i just think that just the
levels in detail sometimes with a safety
aspect
and we really know how to sign but as as
you are saying it's been there for
decades and it's a great facility
one way to continue you know the only
thing just to bear in mind it's
thank you thank you councilman
[Music]
i don't suppose
it's like
longer batches
uh and its weight you must be looking at
25 tons
so it's a bit different to an awesome
car to an ordinary car for a start i
mean if it drops
exactly
[Music]
anticipated increase in vehicle
movements
that arise as a consequence of the cafe
use and
as alluded to previously under the
officer before we consider that the
cafes is limited
by its scale so its capacity will be
multiplied
so in terms of regular movements to and
from the site
um
taken in the context of the wider
standard use of sufficient
suspicion rates
would be significant
consequences as previously mentioned in
terms of being
repairable to that
the owners would be on the landowner to
ensure that it's kept in
the state of
the
environmental health uh approachable
license
uh saying that you have some toilets on
premises whether or not it's for
public use or whatever is irrelevant but
still have to be empty and you have to
use a vehicle like the ceiling
there is a toilet on the side
subjects that actually used by
not only do those use the cash flow but
also by fishing
so is it on the septic tank or is it a
name because
that's my question just having a look
through the application for
i think we need to know
what i'm proposing is there's a road in
and a row down but at the bottom of
there where the three properties are is
where it forks off and over the bridge
into the fishing so there's not two ways
in and out of the place so you've got to
use the bridge
on the bridge
[Music]
[Music]
has been there for more than four years
so if we were seeking to take
enforcement action against the building
on that basis it would be out of time
there is a 10-year time limit in terms
of use
and that's the building is integral to
the use of the summit
the use in officer opinion has been
there for quite ten years the council
will be able to council to take action
to secure a cessation of the use and a
rule of
however i set out in the report
when this was
assessed by the courts in the welling
case
the george and that that
case expressed a view that when a
report when the local planning
authorities allowed the fully approved
reinforcement against the building to
pass
the principle of fairness to the group
governments called inappropriate
circumstances procluded from
subsequently taking enforced action
against under the ten-year-old
so that's the view that we take here
charity of the long-standing use of the
site
in fact the building has been there in
excess of four years and from the
various planning histories that there is
aspect of the wider use of the site but
also
the provision on the site
cafe building over attractive period of
time
probably close some 20 years overboard
so that's
getting some nods from my life so
explain that just as well as i can
but that's the worthy principle
so none of the conditions which were
originally put on uh can be implemented
the building that's been erected on the
side isn't the building that was granted
planning commission in 2012 right if
it's a different building it's not
authorized
in those terms therefore any condition
attached to the 2012 commission
aren't pertinent because the
development's not
doesn't fall back onto the planning
commission it's an unauthorized building
so in effect the cafe
as it stands
would operate without restriction
so very simple in terms of deficient
or
anything such as that
officers have arrived at conclusion that
we have and it's tied back in as far as
1999 with the original commission
congratulate the side
and then even further back to when which
was granted to the wider side to issues
in association with the fishing that
dates back into
expediency etc
but in terms of
the application
as members will be aware you should
consider the application on its merits
not the fact that it's a retrospective
application
uh i hate what members say in terms of
retrospective applications but the
phrase the law stems you need to set
that aside and just consider the
development of this plan
are there any other questions
counselors in cancer and try
yeah is it advertised at the top of
their eye so people
just come into the cafe or is it just
as soon as you went to the site
there are
directions to the to the cafe so if you
were just using the driveway if you go
over the bridge
battery
you would see
signage at
various levels of permanence on the gate
from near to the gate as you get into
the site yes the signage becomes quite
clear that there isn't
that
short term i don't know but i don't
recall c
signage
i've never seen
is there any way that we could recommend
it which is
um
for the weight and somebody has a look
at it
i know we don't really never want to do
it
i'm
in terms of assessing those elements
if members were interested in
a discussion and consideration about
traffic management we would need to go
back to the africans
we brought the issue to
members wanted more information
okay
exactly what i was going to recommend is
that we ask for a deferment you can get
a little bit more clarification on the
security of this bridge i think and and
the weights thing because it is a listed
bridge and also
with the
house
suggestion about looking at one way in
one way out i've got no problem with the
building side of things i just think we
have to look at the city side of
the bridge and also the access in and
out so i personally think that we need
to go to an experiment
with those just for those particular
things in this instance
that's right
adrian can i ask this question i mean i
i have no issue with this we're looking
at we're looking at the veranda stroke
tackle shot
uh and we've
opened up the can of worms with the
safety thing and the bridge and so on
can we deal with this and then get the
other bits going after is that doable
the only way that we could deal with
that i think is if members were reminded
to
which would be to address
those issues by way of condition but
the the outcome of that would be then
practice for officers to consider it
wouldn't be that would bring back to
memphis if we would leave that then for
officers to address issues of sewerage
family
without a doubt so me personally i would
quite happily go down the road to
sorting out this
um application and letting you guys deal
with the safety aspect and the lining of
their own because we need to talk about
widening the top bit for 10 meters or
five meters
in the whole scheme of things it's it's
next next negligible so i'd quietly go
down the route and we'll deal with this
and then let the officers deal with the
other side from dc still the bridge
because i have no doubt if that bridge
fell in
to get pulled up pretty sharply laws and
have no access to the caffeine
facilities anyway
is to
enable vehicles to get off the highway
network so as we step out of the report
it's a matter of convenience for people
using the fishing ponds and all the cafe
and that's not a matter of highway
safety necessarily because the traffic's
very efficient will limit
speed and
removability of vehicles
the issues that we're talking about
it may not result in an appropriate
management system to come through
overleads for example you know
that's the thing and you know that was
off the top that they could do it but
they would have to turn right into
barlow and then if they've gone back to
chesterfield it's unless you did it
it's a really tight bend onto it
and you're on his exact bend as well for
your entrance and exit but it's
something that could be looked at but i
don't think that would alter my opinion
of the actual application
you've been no further questions
this is our opening for the debate
i would like to i know we've discussed
about the bridge if you look on page 21
740.
it doesn't say there that it was a
performer
of
the tackles
and the of johnsville but the bridge was
widened and to take real traffic and
substantially complete examples of
bridge engineering so i would say that
bridge is pretty tough if it's taking
that sort of weight
and you know
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
exceptionally narrow lane
[Music]
[Music]
but i'm quite happy to
listen
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
overall i have no problem with this
the only thing that spoon out to me was
the initial proposed plan and
uh if we're going to widen the track
uh i'll be opening it up to say that the
any future extension will
[Music]
in the future
i think that's something that would come
back to the planning committee at the
time i can't really judge it but it's
not widening the entire traffic
yeah is
[Music]
so the view we talked about
providing vehicles weren't standing on
the highway or having to back up on the
highway as far as because that meant the
highway safety issue was addressed it
generally might have been convenient
to be able
[Music]
impact
retrospective is not against any law
against any plan involved against any
anything the only thing they do is they
run the of us sitting around this table
and saying we don't like to take it down
it's not it's not against anybody
okay
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
yes thank you
please bear in my members that a motion
must be rooted
then the member who has moved the motion
must give the reasons for doing research
the reasons for moving the motion
against officer recommendations
should comprise the relevant planning
issues and be supported by the evidence
as necessary
if a motion to reject officer
recommendations false
or in other words it is not passed
that doesn't mean that the
recommendations are automatically
approved
rather you will need to take a positive
decision to refer the motion and favor
the recommendations of a different
course of action
this will need to be approved by the
committee through another vote
thank you
what
mosquito traffic management
submitted to a degree for themselves
chairman i i can't guarantee that would
result in anything different than we
have at the moment
so does that mean that it's approved as
a recommendation subject to a specific
conditions
um to set out a scheme that works as
discussed and then also a scheme of
traffic management but the final
conditions has been determined by the
development manager
[Music]
that's
abstain
councillor elliot for
councillor lacey
councillor liquid
councillor jones
councillor richmond i'm staying
answer the ramps four
and counselors
so that's six for the motion and five
abstentions
motionless posture
plantation
move on to the second
second application this afternoon is
slash 22 4
two
zero zero six one eight four slash nfl
this takes place in the drawing field
you know
normal practice and wants
us to start
thank you chair first of all just to
refer members to the
single late comments that we received
yesterday apologizing
for being unable to attend this
afternoon
just
this application chair seeks to retain
an agricultural building erected on
land opposite the number of properties
of ocean properties north of tron field
it's an agricultural building
and a state's source to be retained for
the resurrection um initially without
family consent
so that doesn't lie within the green
belt chair does members will be aware
actually
the green belt is appropriate
development
so the primary issue as
referred to by the world council
committee to consider the applications
the impact of the building on the
character of the area
as alice has just
walked up the side
occupies an area of land on the east
side of the former a61 it leaves strong
field north towards the bachelor
roundabout
you can see on the slide there is
already a
well
engineered bell mouth into the side
and that accesses as many members will
know the recently constructed
water management facility in the
river jerome valley to the south east of
where the site is so that's not actually
facilitating the building that was
constructed to facilitate i presume the
building works in the ongoing management
of that
the site has
changed the side chair in that crease
just a large scale shot of that the
building that's been constructed is in
the red top of the slide you see the
track
thank you
once again just
a shot showing the site location chain
just take out the building on the right
hand side row just below the access to
the y shapes
just a couple of slides here to increase
what we saw yesterday that's the picture
of the building you can see the bedroom
we saw on the slides yesterday the
roadside hedge to the right hand side of
there
and then i think the final sliders it's
from the road to the building the report
chair makes records that we thought back
that we talked up yesterday
views of the sides are
about
as we saw yesterday you'll see this site
from across the valley that the
properties that
run along homely lane looking back
across the site but the reasons why we
believe the location this building is
accepted for us
to take any questions
thank you no
so go straight into the questions if
there are any of the offices
that's right
[Music]
let me explain to me how this
fits into the
[Music]
process
[Music]
chair the
construction agricultural buildings in
greenbelt is considered appropriate
development so in terms of australia
greenbelt policy the building is
designed and used for agriculture so
would be appropriate development in
those circumstances
[Music]
any other questions
yeah and i saw some more in the lecture
in malaysia
recommended would prescript no external
likes and so it wouldn't have included
fighting within the buildings just to
try and
ensure that the
there will be lights in the vicinity
from the traffic and from the
streetlights
questions
the local plan
uh ss1 supports substantial sustainable
development which protects and enhances
the character quality and diversity of
the district green industry a local
landscape and a wider countryside
this building does not enhance
or help the character it detracts from
it
local planned policy
ss9 respect the form scale and character
of the landscape
to design materials contrary to this it
doesn't respect the
counsellor
recommended to it
right
right uh ss d3 the london plan is
concerning protecting distinctiveness of
character
um
and it's an important feature of this
particular the field is open so i don't
think it does detract
from this
and then the local planet s these 12
uh
is
that
the quality of the materials on the
building and
the quality of the building and the
design of it isn't appropriate for where
it says
the building becomes very very apparent
are there
it it is after all a lamin pen a laming
shelter
i don't know how much you could enhance
any field with a
laminate
[Music]
is that building is an agricultural
building therefore
needs to be located in that cultural
setting
and in our views against the hedgerow
and close to that new junction is
you the best location for the building
in this case
if it was a matter that you wish to have
additional softening of the building
then you may impose a condition to
require landscaping for example and you
could condition on requiring the
attention to be retained to certain
kinds
and it would of course require
maintenance going forward and ultimately
that's the judge that the members need
to make
clearly if you require the view that
it's inappropriate for those reasons
adversely that's the character of the
location and the next step will be
foreign
[Music]
recommendation
i'll second that chair and i agree with
what orleans just said and if we can
soften it build the screen around it
whether they raise the ground levels
around it to
save any
whichever way they want
to stay as an agricultural building to
retain the hedge height and
supplement by any other way
like that with angel
but if we get their memories
to grant consent on those basis that
basis checks certainly the
problem is the condition and it will be
built in braces requiring them to use
only fractional purposes
and but i would suggest those in
members of my needs to
to say granted over those terms would be
secure
conditional landscaping scheme and
management
[Music]
okay so please be clear that members is
to approve officer recommendations the
attention of the building as an
agricultural building for cultural
purposes and then with appropriate
management scheme to ensure
appropriate screening of the building
takes place retention balance
and basis
for counsellor cloth
for
consultation
answer alliance for
counselor laci
or
counselor leaders
councillor jones
councillor ridgeway
council ramps for
and council growth
that's unanimous chair the emotions
passed
thank you dancers
there's a
limited
things to say heroin you would see that
the dismissal of the appeal
weekly just make interesting reading
share in terms of
health policy and potential ancient
women so as with all the decisions it's
worth worth reading
i'll just leave it to that and in terms
of the other appeals chair you will
notice that we've had a lot of appeals
coming through so it is
bringing with its consequences
with any of the decisions hopefully
members are still receiving those
decisions
okay
[Music]
you